in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Daniel
and Scarlett are with us hey guys how
are you
welcome welcome where y'all from we are
from Palmer Texas which is just south of
Dallas yeah sure yeah good to have you
come true
well thanks so you're here to do a
debt-free sir you are yes sir how much
have you paid off
we paid off thirty three thousand one
hundred and twenty two months excellent
and making what kind of income during
that time we started at 85,000 and we
ended at 105 thousand excellent what do
you guys do for a living so I'm a
business analyst I'm an auto take it
Arsenal very cool
good good job so what kind of debt was
just 33,000 hey we had everything a
credit card surcharges for all tickets
IRS a trailer home that we use this for
in a home which was stupid personal loan
to my ex-father-in-law 401k loan former
home a toolbox and student loans a
personal loan to your ex fathers awkward
how much did you owe him $5,500 yeah oh
my gosh okay yeah Daniel was ready to
get rid of that loan for sure bad so
tell me about the trailer what'd you do
with it oh my goodness um so it was
something that we saw in a facebook swap
site for $3,500 and for some reason we
thought hey this would be a good idea to
be an investment property which totally
didn't work out and we were doing this
long lease to own option with the tenant
so right about 10 months ago when we
were in the homestretch of our you know
a Total Money Makeover debt snowball we
found out that the tenant had totally
trashed the trailer and to the point
where they rotted out the subfloor and
all our brand-new flooring and it was a
mess and they'd taken off and I mean it
was it was horrible so what'd you do
with it we sold it well how much did it
bring well for all our blood sweat and
tears are brought a thousand dollars but
we cleared you know what we owed on it
plus $1,000 oh you made money it's just
a thousand dollars but you got a hole
that's good that's true
so that was part of the formula you sold
the trade mm-hmm okay and so what
happened 22 months ago that puts you
guys on this journey to be debt-free
well we got married in April of 2014 and
we bought a house right before that in
January mm-hmm and you know when we were
filling out the mortgage paperwork I
thought we were doing great because our
cars were paid off and we only had one
credit card and hardly anything on it
and you know we realized when we add it
all up we owed thirty three thousand one
hundred dollars and it was like where
did all this come from mm-hmm and they
were going even more in debt for our new
home and it was just overwhelming cuz
I'll talk to my cousin about it and she
recommended your books to me and your
podcast and so I started listening and I
think the first week I listened you
mentioned something about the average
American has only one bad car wreck away
from bankruptcy mm-hmm and that hit home
I really hit home so we we decided as
soon as we get married we're doing this
okay you got the book because your
cousin recommended then you're listening
this stuff and Daniel she's talking to
you about it what are you saying yeah
that's fun well it worked out for you
that's for sure very cool so what do you
all say the keys to getting out of debt
are well definitely the budget and I
would say redefine your sense of
entertainment mm-hmm like we had a lot
of good times just hanging out in the
garage on Saturday night barbecuing or
mm-hmm after church I know this is kind
of crazy but like instead of going out
to eat like most of our friends we would
go to Kwik Trip and pick up nine ounce
and hot dogs yeah go to the park and you
know it was just those little things and
I wouldn't say that we suffered through
it I mean it was you know just to change
a pace and it was nice and just had to
be creative about it and think about it
yeah when we were broke we used to talk
kids hey we're going to a restaurant
after church they go yeah no he just say
Sharon's restaurant oh yeah although
Sharon's restaurants really good but the
kids wanted to go out to eat you know
but we you know we totally wanted to
torture them psychologically so so you
brought the kids with you we did we got
Erebus and
adhi and sages hanging out over there
okay very cool good and have they been
practicing they have been I would say
when we started this one month after we
started we found out we were pregnant so
we just put the whole thing on pause and
we cash flowed her arrival her birth and
eight weeks of unpaid maternity we cash
flowed that as well Wow she's a she's a
beauty all three of them are nice
absolutely alright well girls get over
there let's get ready to do our
debt-free scream $33,000 paid off it's
Daniel and scarlet and the girls
twenty-two months it took them selling
the trailer doing a couple other things
being on the debt or being on the budget
eighty-five thousand one hundred and
five thousand in income count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream that's how
it's done right there man that's how you
get her done well done you guys very
well done very proud of you you got to
feel great about this very fun hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you